[Music]
kelly is with us in baltimore maryland
hi kelly welcome to the ramsey show
hi oh my gosh it's such an honor thank
you for having me
our honor too how can we help
i
am
drowning in student loan debt um
i have three hundred thousand dollars on
student loans oh honey
yes
what's your degree in are you a lawyer
or a doctor
a lawyer okay that's good news
i hope i hope you got a good lawyer job
you didn't take a work take a job with a
state or something
the government federal government why
uh work-life balance so uh work-life
balance you got 300 000 in debt
i know
i did have a mental health breakdown
back in 2018
and that pr i couldn't find a job so the
government was the first one that came
up at the end of 2019 and then the
pandemic hit
yeah how much i pay in you
uh my gross is nine thousand eight
hundred thirty four
okay how long you've been in law school
uh twenty fifteen
how are you doing with your mental
health
uh better i see a therapist bi-weekly um
that's a part of my my my budget is that
i have to pay my co-pay for my therapist
um and i see the psychiatrist quarterly
so then i take medication good
investment good investment well done
thank you
sounds like you're doing better
i am much better and
um
realizing that i gotta
get a hold of all of this
my wife
i'm not married but i still am with my
children's father okay
how many kids do you have
three
what age
sixteen
seven going on eight and four going on
five
all right um
well you gotta you got a mountain to
climb here
and so we got to get our climbing gear
out and uh
the hole that you're in is 300 000 the
shovel that you have is 90 000.
right
yes your income we call it the shovel to
hole ratio your income versus the amount
of debt you got to climb through
and so i start going okay out of 89 out
of 90 000 how quick can i pay off 300 or
if i pound 30 a year that's 10 years
that doesn't work
yes too long i even tried to
work some things out and i'm like it's
still too long
it was like five
magic like six years and i was like
that's like five thousand more months
and i'm like i don't know
i do uh try to work on the side i need
to um
i do uh probate
and some estate planning but it's just
been slow going
only 500 there 500 there
so now that things are settled a bit
after 2018 and the pandemic and
everything are you open to finding a
different job that maybe pays a bit more
um i did not think of it no i didn't i
am open but i did not think of that yeah
okay because you you need to you could
probably make 160 you probably double
your income 170 if you got out there in
private practice um
and
i mean it might take a little bit of
time to get there but
you're not going to get there in the job
you're in
and you need a bigger shovel
mathematically the arithmetic tells us
that because if you could put um 80 on
this you'd be done in three or four
years
but you can't put 80 on it when you make
90. you can when you make 180.
and yeah there's going to be some
work-life balance
but i'm going to go with some work-life
balance
uh like that mom's going to work because
mom has a mess
and uh i'll see you in about three years
well especially if you make that shovel
bigger then it's less about side
hustling and working 80 or 90 hours it
might be at a new law firm a private law
firm they might put her in there that's
true and
lock her on the fifth floor not let her
out but um but at least you'll have the
the income there like your salary will
be a lot stronger than what it is
currently
here the probability of you getting this
mess cleaned up increases the more you
can shorten how long the pain is going
to be
and so i i for your sake i i think
you've got to reconsider
how you can go make double what you make
or you know uh almost double what you
make and throw it all throw all the
difference at it because i mean does it
not sound pretty appealing to be out of
debt in three or four years
yes
i mean i would give up i would give up a
lot of stuff to do that i'd give up a
lot of a sacrifice to do that when we
started this company i worked my kids
were your kids age or younger and for
three years my wife will tell you she
was virtually a single mom when we
started this company but if you work
like no one else later you get to work
like no one else
and if you live like no one else later
you get to live like no one else and
here's the thing the the amount of time
that human beings in america waste in
front of the television
will really cause you to prosper alone
and you don't you can't call work
sitting in front of the television work
life balance because children aren't
getting anything out of that except
watching mom and dad zone out watching
netflix and tiger king
and so um
you know i i
i don't recommend working 80 hours a
week and never seeing your children as a
way of life but for a short period of
time to get some kind of a needle to
move yeah hard work never killed anybody
right before you die you pass out if
you're working hard
so you're not going to die from it
well good job having the courage to call
you've been through you've been through
a lot yeah that's that's and you have a
huge mountain ahead but we have seen
people pay off three hundred thousand
dollars in debt here's the thing the
looming
monster
that's
thirty thousand pounds three hundred
thousand pound monster here
three hundred thousand dollar monster
there's a stress
and a weight
to that that dr john deloney
you know our resident psychologist says
your body
feels that weight
it affects your mental health
and so for you to
continue the healing you have to see a
way out of that
instead of seeing that as this endless
rock you have to push up the hill
as in greek mythology right and so uh
you know you push the rock up the hill
and you get to keep pushing it up the
hill for the rest of your life that
there's that the weight of that
hopelessness
affects your mental health it affects
literally your physical body feels that
as a from a mental health perspective
your physiological reactions to the debt
and so um
you know you even if the
news is hard
hope that it's going to be over soon
i can deal with the hard news
right yeah the human being human mind
can be a psyche can deal so my point is
it's going to help your mental health to
have a plan that gets you out right yeah
the idea of carrying around 300 000 in
student loan debt for the rest of your
life that sounds terrifying i think
anybody would feel that pit in their
stomach and just such a
just a rough feeling feeling like that
monster is chasing you and it's right
there all the time but yes there is hope
this is scary right now
but you can tackle this you can tackle
this mountain as hard as it is
i think especially given the career that
you're in given that you can get a
bigger shovel and really attack this i
understand how you got to the career and
i'm not shaming you for that i would
tell you not to stay there though
because i think it's good for you good
for your finances good for your kids
good for your mental health good for
your career for you to go make a big
pile of money and get this mess behind
you yes
and so that that's why i'm saying all of
this it's not just to get you out of
debt
because there's so much more to this
picture
and uh but it's
uh uh
the number of families that we have had
with small children
that
both spouses
the kids ended up at grandma's half the
time because they were hustle grind
they're working two three four jobs and
18 24 36 months later they've cleared
all the debt now they can work 40-hour
jobs the rest of their life and become
very very wealthy
and the kids are not harmed by that
because it's not a permanent way of life
we're not working for the wrong reasons
we're working for a short period of time
with intensity with gazelle intensity
for focus get it knocked out that does
not harm your children no and those are
the best debt-free screams when we hear
them in here just yelling at the top of
their lungs that they did it it is so
powerful and we hope to see you here
kelly in a few years amen